はいというわけでドクターストーンの収録でございますあのありがたい事に本当に
ちょっと生口に出させていただけるということで単独さんからも降り切ってやれと指示
を頂いたので降り切って頑張っていきたいとおもいます
ドクターストンでやって混ぜやばいからプロ種
やるぞ
[音楽]
いいえ
あ
[音楽]
ています
はいというわけで chrome 役の佐藤
チェーン度かいい
を知って抑えはじめではなく黒役佐藤件でございますどうぞよろしくお願いしまーす
ねえ
感じが一緒ですねあそうなんですよ僕もあのねお名前改めて観させていただい時に
a 4まで一生っっはしか過ぎだようーってないよ
はい
届くたストリート見させていただきありがとうございませ黒役ということでハイあの
クロムって何かあっほしいですよねあの
そうですね彼自身がその選挙の相棒としてよくか通訳させていただくんですけどもあの
彼自身ものすごく科学が大好きそういう書くという字を知る前から直行これは何だろう
という
うちもせな子だったので戦空と出会ってより
もともとあった才能が磨かれていく
すごい成長を楽しめるけど
ぶーぶー&ですよもうだから僕自身もあのプルーンやらせていただけるプロセス後ろで
聞いてままじゃ
ガーン技本当にかかってたんですけど
4ベイほどうめえって来たことを撮影ナビゲーションできたらと思うのではいぜひ
宜しくお願いますよろしくお願いしますありがとうございます
名前が欲しいバッハ宜しくお願いします
お久しぶりですよございますよね数ヶ月ぶりですか
ディフェクトのしかなくてもいや言う空今までそんなことで焼いた実験的な
アーティストとチャンネルでご一緒に夏1走でスネ最終回実は最終回のこの台詞って
いう心構えでこの第2期
頑張ってきたとどうしても心政府だけはすごいいいセリフにしたいって自分の中目標が
あってそれを
まあ自分の中ではすごくうまく落とし込めだろう
声が良すぎるんですよ本部よねえええでもあまりキャラクターと地声が結構離れている
そうですね線空間は無理そうなんですよね
意外とどのキャラやってもあんまり g とは違う
か自問声を染められて
あの子も好きですねあ戦空の声が本当に音とですよねちょっと色っぽいですよね選挙の
これなんかそんなつもりはないんですけど仕組みにダスッ
低めにはいそうです低めに出してますしちょっと行き多めにもしているのでそう
本当に最高数ありがとう
チョイ役で出させていただいてるな
でもさっき外で聞いていったのと後親子とみんなに着替えてるんですかこれまさか
でも音響監督さんも降る前は
いや以前夏ちょっと一緒にやりたいと殺すよろしくお願いしますはい健吾さんですよ
ああそれじゃあやもうほんと毒+とずっと言っちゃうからあーよし
おっしゃいますけどすごいも結構朝食るっぽいああそうですねなんかちょっとああいう
破天荒なキャラクターなんですけどちょっとあの
なるべく地声に近いような感じではしかしていただきか夏けどちょっと
ロスね朝霧ぎゃあああいう風にあたってどういうところな気をつけたり
ああああそうですねすごいペラッペラな男なので私なので何でしょうねライダーシーン
でもちょっと重くならないように
まあなロードライトな感じないとな感じでみんな後深刻になっているけど彼だけは
ちょっと楽しいんですけどそんな感じでは age
させていただいてますね彼が入ってからこそ年カチッとその刃の部分が明るくなったり
する場面もあるのですごい大事に行くだと思ってるんですよ
最初はちょっとだけ
あっ条約で出されててああもう面白くてくれ
いやーこざぶ聞かれてましたあっちょっ
じゃあなあーんだ山がもう関係はまだ聞いてないのでいうことですね
シャローとかいやいやも外で今季でてるんですが
いやをはそんなわけでいただける英明原作だねまだまだ続いているので出来れば
あれまんですけどいきます
行かせましょう以下じゃちょっとカッコつくと動画ちょっと違いました
宜しくお願いしますよろしくお願いしますあじゃあ1年だとちゃいます
えっそそるぜこれは正解
100億満点やるよ味目社長
[音楽]
pr
い最後にバリュウムプーチ小宮
スライムからの炎の爆誕米
エアー会えだ太鼓ねー
ちー今デバイヤー
1009ちゃん味めちゃん
ございます
武芸
5位ぞこれはよろしくお願いますねますおーやってやや
愛車カーたーーー
まじかやべぇ
始め者ちゃありがとうござ
71 p ございますありがとうございます
いうわけで完璧に朝切る前選挙車の素材が集まりますので
これは元に毒竜党の3人がいる政界にもし始め社長がいたらの話を完全に作ります
今日はすごいゲストが家に来て実験をしてくれるって聞いたけど誰が来るんだ
ア二メ射場肇社長はじめ
すごい前偶然前にクンニ朝霧店
今日は俺の家ですごい実機を見せてくれるって本当
やってやや
フードがやってくれるの
無知かやべーなんで自分で驚いてんだよ
全球ちゃんあやっぱり旋回先生がやってくれるんですね
セグ先生よろしくお願いしますこうやってや薬を通したクロム
チーマーデパイヤーやっ本当に幻の言う通りだよ
なーんてライダー2戦空が俺何を燃やしてるぞ
うちの親父さん何してなんだ
一そそるぜくる今井そそるんじゃないよ
4 a
でもこれも実験なんだよいっ
英語に bar room
これは a
まさか
a 食反応
100億満点やる
ジャガーあっあああ
狩野さん今俺言いますよねそれ正解100億満点いう前人生
無知かやべえやばいのあんたよ大丈夫か
エリーゼくれ
ライムからの炎の爆誕で
物質を燃やすと特製の色になるこれが
尺八ああ
小さなせれば year
あっは
[音楽]
bl